the jurogan experience like i want these
guys to get the bag
and like there's something about like
calling somebody out which you
immediately respect them a little bit
more like willing to put yourself out
there for a fight
he called out conor mcgregor too that's
what jake's doing
that kid is a master troll dude he's a
master creating hype like
dude if i'm dana white i'm praying that
this guy can actually
a jake paul amanda nunes boxing match
that's because dana said uh
dana said um maybe i'll let amanda news
knock him out um
that's just not good for anybody i hope
they don't do that that's just not good
for everybody yeah but the question is
could you can't sleep on that kid
that kid can [ __ ] crack yeah when you
look at how he knocked nate robinson out
that short hand that he threw was very
skillful real punch
that was a real punch it was perfectly
placed and
he can hit hard all three punches were
the same thing
they're a step back overhand right yeah
you
that's that's not like got lucky that's
hey this guy doesn't know what he's
doing so he's going to charge at you
just step back and lay a right hand on
him yeah i mean he knew exactly
it was skillful and that was in the
middle of a wild brawl where nate
robinson was trying to take his head off
and it was kind of unorthodox right so
it's it's dangerous because
nate is super strong he's a crazy
athlete unreal athlete
winging punches at him and so he's got
to figure his way through this
this maze of bombs headed his way and he
clips him
you know here it is i think if you look
at him look at him look at how
how well he moves away yeah this is the
beginning ties up well
boom but he's he's good just at tying up
and using defense
and nate was [ __ ] dangerous man you
saw him try to throw the right right
there
yeah yeah
he's he's a skillful boxer man yeah he
really is like legitimately serious
i mean he's not world class
right now but he is 23 years old
yeah i mean he got a real damn that
that's one that folded him but that's
not the one that folded him ultimately
he got up off of that one
and he'd get ko'd by the next one you
know they should have stopped it right
there well he was complaining to the
referee that got hit behind the head
which is
hilarious that was so ridiculous yeah
yeah i think i think he realized at this
point in time that this is not
it's not just athleticism involved here
that's what's going on
in boxing that you have to you have to
understand what a fight is
it's you're you're at war with yourself
as much as you're at war with that other
person you have to keep
keep back it up jamie let's see that
punch
yeah so let this play out so
if you watch how he knocks this dude out
like even the way he's moving his body
game over i don't think that's it no
that's the second one that's
yeah that's just a knock down yeah here
it is
here it is bang that's the one when you
see a guy
face plant like that and bounce yeah
that's a wrap
yeah to play it back just just let it
play but if you watch how he did it
look at this that's a short punch man
yep he didn't wind that up he stepped
back and put it in place
he's got skill and he's only 23.
if he decides to dedicate himself to
actually being a boxer yeah
and spends all of his time boxing and
then talking [ __ ] and doing podcasts
yeah you [ __ ] never know man yeah he
he might go a long way he
obviously can perform under pressure he
obviously has legitimate power yeah he's
got legitimate skill yeah and he's
dedicated why not do it if you're connor
50 million to beat up the guy to talk
some [ __ ] about your wife first of all
it was wild what he said about his wife
i didn't see what he said about his wife
he said you didn't see this video no
oh my god bro i don't need to see that
we didn't need to broadcast that
okay fine but everybody's seen it by the
way he just called his yeah he's just
called his wife of four
wow yeah and it's he only follows one
girl on instagram
connor's wife oh my god yeah he knows
how to play the trolling game
hilarious so it's like it's a he's a
wild boy but he understands what he's
doing
just the other day that's what connor
does that i mean talk about talking
about people's wives
conor did that to jose aldo
yeah yeah yeah but like
it was it was just wild man and then
recently yeah i mean like the guy knows
what he's doing he was in uh
la and i think i think it was that
brendan schaub's show like this dylan
danis
you know he was like doing the food
truck thing yeah and he i guess he has
some beef with jake paul jake wants to
fight him
so he pulls up on the back of a pickup
truck with water balloons and wet toilet
paper
and starts chucking it at him while he's
doing the interview this is it
the guy knows how to be there oh
somebody's talking
how did he know he was going to be
somebody's talking his brother did it
a couple days before
but dylan danis ran up to him and he
sped away why didn't he get out and
fight him
yeah that's what a lot of people are
saying this is kind of soft like he came
at you well
let me tell you something yeah dylan
dennis gets a hold of you he's a wrap
your arm's broken
you're getting your neck strangled off
yeah as a bad guy
he's going to rip your knees apart he's
that good not a [ __ ] chance in the
world yeah
really oh if dylan dennis is a world
class grappler top of the food chain
yeah he's like
i mean he he's a guy who who i'm pretty
sure he went to a draw
with gordon ryan who is the lead of the
elite
i see him in the uh maybe beat him by
decision by like one point or something
like that
what's going on in this this is that 50
million he just
posted was proof of funds got you
curious huh notorious mma
so he's showing take the fight [ __ ] who
said take the fight so jake paul says to
conor take the fight [ __ ] in a dm
and then he showed that conor saw the dm
he's just this kid like okay so there's
different ways to like build hype
obviously like you can build hype by
just creating you know uh
great content you can build hype by
creating drama and you can build hype by
creating like a villain-esque attitude
right yes and this guy has no problem
being the villain
he if he likes to talk [ __ ] about dylan
dennis i think it would be hilarious if
they had uh an mma match
well i don't think he wants to do the
mma one but he's trying to get dylan to
do the boxing
but that's why i ran away from dylan
because it's a real box
gloves and dylan grabs you done that's a
there's a whole different world song but
could he beat him in a box i don't know
enough about dylan but could he beat him
in a boxing match he might be able to
but if you're dead that's not his world
so diaz
you spoil [ __ ] you can't really fight
dumb [ __ ] you're gonna end up with your
ass what for real somewhere talking like
that
tell me you don't want to see this fight
dude it feels like the 90s with rap beef
it's west coast east coast like they're
really doing it hilarious
but tell me you don't want to see nate
and him fight well i do these guys are
trying to make money
let them make some money i'm just like
that's how you make money more what is
this
you said you saw what happened to the
other nate
so the kid knows what he's doing he
knows how to build hype oh yeah
he doesn't mind i guess being hated no
he doesn't mind which is a value-added
value
look and he's very respectful after the
fight's over like with roberts he was
very respectful
yeah he was i think it is he is playing
the the character i mean we've seen you
know conor do we've seen floyd do it
we've seen guys like really lean into it
too hyped to fight
who knows what happens after the fight
but you got to still keep on playing the
character and you can't deny that
the [ __ ] that understand how to
troll or garner interests are the guys
who are going to make the most money
100 like you see the guy i keep on
telling izzy i'm like bro
i mean darren till's got to get some
wins but like a fight between you and
darren
the lead up on social media is going to
be the most fun
yeah non-stop back and forth they're
making money
light heavyweight you know he's fighting
yon blehovic sure sure but like is he's
fighting right for the title
right right right but still the idea of
having those two guys who really
understand
because remember when i said he was
going to fight yol and i was like stop
fighting guys that don't speak english
we can't do anymore it's like
it could be a fun fight but like which
that one was not but like
i want the hype i want you to make as
much money as possible you know i mean i
want people the casual fan to be
interested
how do you get the casual catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience